hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
anthem first grabbed our attention at e3
last year but surprisingly fell silent
shortly after now one year later details
are finally here to add a little more
context to anthem so much so that we
have a release date February 22nd of
2019 so here's everything we learned
about anthem at e3 2018 I'd love to talk
about the javelin suit right away but
first let's figure out where we start
the game the world of anthem is
deliberately unfinished and ambiguous
the gods that created this world known
as shapers used a powerful piece of
technology known as the anthem of
creation to form each element of the
planet for an unbeknownst reason those
gods left the planet half complete but
the tools they created the world with
still remain scattered throughout the
world with all that godlike tech laying
around it's only a question of when
someone will attempt to use it for evil
so that's where we step in we play as
the freelancers a specially trained
group of operatives who are capable of
piloting a javelin
a futuristic excel suit which looks to
be ironmans wet dream the javelins are
characterized by four subsets Ranger
Colossus interceptor and storm the devs
have shed a little light on the classes
starting with the Ranger which is a
general suit which is balanced and
thrives on up close and personal combat
the Colossus on the other hand is
described as a specialized unit
utilizing heavy artillery we've seen him
wielding a mortar and a flamethrower
the Colossus who is quickly becoming my
personal favorite was also shown
charging through mines with his shield
for cover we didn't hear much about the
Interceptor class or storm for that
matter but we can see by the demo
footage the Interceptor looks to be more
agile and the storm class uses elemental
powers we could apply traditional MMO
and RPG roles to the javelins with the
range of being the DPS the Colossus
could be the tank the storm could be a
mage and at a push the Interceptor is a
healer maybe not let's leave that on the
Shelf until we see their skill sets in
future reveals the devs have also noted
that each chaplain class was based on
the elements a major point to be stated
is that you play as a pilot not a
javelin therefore you can pick and
choose which exosuit you want to take on
each mission you and your chosen squads
will need to balance the weapons the
items and the javelins you choose to
complement one another especially in
difficult endgame activities but on the
other hand you could jump in alone after
a hard day grab the Colossus and destroy
everything in your path the choice is
yours we also know that each javelin
class has unique skills melee attacks
defensive setups and good old Ultimates
to use when more info is released I'll
be back to break down each Javelin class
especially the storm so that leads us
onto the enemies in anthem the native
wildlife always possesses a potential
risk but who will be the main villain of
the
in terms of the narrative-driven enemy
your fall will be the Dominion these
folks are aggressive wicked and
malicious and they're attempting to
harness the power of the gods
aka the anthem of creation to build
super weapons designed to bring down
your javelin and anything else you love
too and on top of that unconfirmed alien
invaders known as scars are here to keep
both sides on their toes in a constant
three-way power struggle anthem is
trying to give us questions we want to
find answers to we've been told that the
story is solo driven but it's also a
fully-fledged shared world so you'll
need up to three friends to be with you
every endeavor and mission any destiny
players in the house remember the first
time you've finished a raid and the
awesome memories that invokes well
that's what anthem wants but with all
aspects of the game immersive and
emergent gameplay they call it although
this is very much a shared world shooter
there is one place you cannot take your
friends with you your home hub of fort
Asus locked behind a massive wall to
keep out the enemy you'll return here
often to hand in quests and to chat with
the occasional NPC or two this will act
as your campaign home which is solely
for you to signify this change the
camera will switch to first-person
whenever you go back home so
third-person for the shared world
first-person for when you're back at fob
Tarsus so why would fort Asus be a
private experience it's pretty simple by
making this zone a solitary place anthem
can make changes to your private world
that reflects where you are in the
game's narrative maybe for Tarsus was
invaded and buildings were demolished
you'd see that devastation when
returning home whereas your mate Dave
may not be that far in the story and we
wouldn't ruin it for him I'm curious to
know your opinion on our private refuge
we call for Tarsus do you want to share
your home base I'll keep the narrative
changes to yourself there are many RPG
elements at work in anthem both centered
around your pilots and each respective
javelin for example investing in your
pilot's with an ability such as jumping
higher with jets this will be given to
all your javelins whereas any upgrades
to your traveling specifically remain on
that single javelin let's take this
point further and look at customization
in anthem the first way you'll stand out
from your friends on the battlefield is
the two weapons you choose to bring
along although we haven't seen the full
range of weapons available yet we know
that anthem will use weapon rarities to
signify the epicness of each firearm and
collectible in last year's demo the
Ranger picked up Yara's wrath the
legendary vault rifle showing us that
weapons do indeed have levels applied
and have stats broken down into damage
accuracy range rate of fire and ammo
capacity here's something I found quite
interesting whilst on a mission with a
light javelin such as the interceptor or
storm you may find a weapon which can
only be used with a heavier frame ie the
Ranger or the super-heavy Colossus
forcing you to change your character and
play style to utilize that new weapon in
addition to this along with the weapons
you choose you have two extra slots for
tools such as energy explosives or good
old grenades to name a few
in terms of aesthetic customization
anthem is all about expression we're
talking complete paint jobs only a small
portion were shown but that included a
Mass Effect Easter Egg and this paint
job which I'll be forcing all my clan to
wear customization and monetization come
hand-in-hand these days which were also
addressed by the devs loot boxes will
not exist in anthem but purchasable
items will but they won't offer any
gameplay advantages it's all about
cosmetics only if you haven't guessed
already anthem is intended to be played
for years it's an ongoing service which
promises to dynamically change and
evolve during its lifespan will be
grinding through missions to find the
perfect weapon upgrading our characters
and equipment will be building
relationships with NPCs and more
importantly other players in the world
will be fighting enemies with super
weapons and attempting to save humanity
we'll be living every moment which we
are told is filled with deep exploration
and law for months and years of
I can't say if anthem will be a great
game but I can say it has a great deal
of potential what do you guys think
anthem releases on February 22nd 2019 on
ps4 Xbox and PC I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
you